ah we're getting ready to celebrate
valentine's day and of course that means
lots of good chocolates here with a few
treats that are perfect for the season
is chef and owner karis kawana thanks
for being here of course thanks for
having us i really appreciate it you
have been doing this for about a dozen
years or more right yeah quite a bit
around around vegas and so i'm really
lucky we have a like a small business
and we're presenting our treats for
valentine's day actually starting eighth
at all the coffee bean locations how did
you get started in this what oh
gosh well i love to eat
i'm with you so far i love the sweets
and um we just i just decided that i
wanted to do something on my own and
our company does
so much around the board and they let me
ha do my business through coffee bean
and it's been really really a blessing
especially with during the pandemic
people have been very very supportive so
thank you so much for for having me
congratulations on all your success too
so people can find your stuff at coffee
bean and tea leaf anywhere else just all
those locations all the locations are
coffee bean and tea leaf
in nevada okay yeah and so tell us what
you're doing right now so right now um
we this is one of our favorites it's a
we do cake pops but we're going to do a
little bit more we'll do some cake
truffles so chocolate of course this is
where our specialties and i'm just going
to coat it with a little bit of dark
chocolate and we're going to if you
could help anything can you sprinkle a
little bit of that on on there
i mean sprinkles is a lot of love right
right absolutely sprinkle it with love
so
we also offer these cupcakes which is
our red velvet with cream cheese butter
and buttercream with a little bit of
our candy sprinkles and and some rice
krispies oh that sounds fantastic now do
you do this out of your home or how do
you i do not
we're located downtown and a small a
bakery
really tidy i don't have a storefront
just yet but we're working on it you're
doing great as it stands thanks for the
vegas support and like so people walk
into a coffee bean and tea leaf and they
go yeah coffee whatever but they want
paris sweets right right right so do
they ask for it or is it out on display
they ask for it and there is um some
some of the the products that are
they're there so there's like carrot
cake and we have a bunch of vegan
products um
some of our pastries are done in-house
too so the croissants uh you name it my
lemon bar is my favorite so can people
order directly from you have you had do
you do that as well or is it all
all through coffee beans for now for now
yeah guys
and there's only one of me
i love it though that's fantastic what
else do you have in addition to what
you're showing us today uh
we have to today just um for valentine's
day the the rice krispie treat and the
cake truffle they come in the box it
it's really cute we're going to try to
do um as many as we can for for
valentine's day um and for the week of
um
limited edition it's just something that
we're going to do for the week is this
your biggest time of year oh valentine's
day
for every pastry chef yes yeah yeah well
congratulations on all the success
character you're a delightful you gotta
come back okay oh thank you so much this
is so much fun i i love it and i'm gonna
be eating these on the commercial break
so i can't wait for that meantime let's
head over to mercedes
thanks